a big part of language learning is  starting to notice the patterns of the  language every time you pay a little  attention to a word or a phrase that you  have saved a link let's say that you  move the status up from two to three  which you can do manually let's say that  you create a tag  let's say that you review your links of  the day which are sent to you according  to a a spaced repetition system in other  words designed to help you remember them  before you completely forget them all of  these things help you notice  and you should pay attention when you  see certain phrases maybe phrases that  you have saved and tagged if you hear  them again try to pay a little attention  to it the more you deliberately try to  notice things whether it be  pronunciation structure relationship  between  words that might have similar meanings  all of this effort to notice is going to  help your brain eventually  keep these things in your long-term  memory so make an effort to notice